Taraja Ramsess, a stunt performer whose film
credits include "Black Panther," "Avengers:
Endgame," and "The Suicide Squad," died on
October 31st in a vehicle collision in Georgia.
He was 41 years old.
His four children were also in the vehicle
with him, two of whom also died at the scene,
while his 10-year-old son was placed on life
support, but died shortly thereafter.
The crash happened shortly before midnight
on Halloween night.
"They say that he was on his way home when
his truck and an eighteen-wheeler collided."
Ramsess' mother confirmed the news on Instagram,
writing,
"All who knew and met him know how special
Taraja was.
He had a deep capacity for love and loved
his children more than all.
He loved his martial arts, motorcycles and
all things related to filmmaking.
He [had] a very droll yet wicked sense of
humor & yet could be as cornball corny as can be."
Director Ava DuVernay released her own statement
to Instagram.
Ramsess was a crew member for the "Selma"
filmmaker's distribution company, ARRAY.
DuVernay wrote,
"Taraja.
Regal.
That's the word that comes to mind when I
think of him.
He walked like a king.
And to me, always acted like one.
[...] He loved making movies and TV too.
Held many positions over the years.
Immersing himself in all aspects of the craft."
Ramsess' passing is a devastating loss to
the stunt community, with him having helped
bring to life numerous moments from some of
the most popular films of the last several years.
Ramsess brought his passion for martial arts
into a variety of stunt work for numerous
high-profile projects.
His first stunt credit came in 2015 when he
served as a stunt double for Papa Midnite
in an episode of "Constantine."
From there, he appeared in a string of comic
book adaptations, doing stunts for "Black
Lightning," "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law," and
"Black Adam."
He even has some on-camera appearances, as
he appears as a Wakandan soldier in "Avengers:
Infinity War" and a groomsman in “What Men
Want.”
Ramsess also had experience in the art department
for various productions.
He's worked as an on-set dresser, who is responsible
for arranging objects on a set before the
cameras roll, on many film and TV sets, including
"The Hunger Games: Catching Fire," "Furious
7," and "What Men Want."
Looking over his resume, it becomes abundantly
clear that Ramsess was a singular talent who
excelled in many different disciplines.
He was a key behind-the-scenes figure who
will be missed by all those who worked with him.
Numerous professionals have populated his
mother's Instagram tribute with kind words
of their own to remember how dedicated Ramsess
was to his craft.
Fashion designer Tameka Foster empathized
with her situation, posting,
"As a Mom who has lost a son, my heart breaks
for you.
I am truly sorry for your loss.
I will pray for your grandbabies as well."
Actor Carrie Bernans shared her own special
connection with Ramsess, posting,
"My deepest condolences [...] He was truly
an incredible person to work with.
We worked on the set of Black Panther together
and he's always been such a joy to be around
and full of life and love.
Sending you all so much prayers & love."
Ramsess' passing is a huge loss both for the
entertainment community and his immediate family.
After his death, a GoFundMe was established
for his mother to help cover any forthcoming
expenses, and has already received more than
$87,000 in donations, as of the making of this video.